una vez que ya hemos entendido el
concepto de calidad la siguiente
habilidad que vamos a adquirir es la de
identificar un centro quiral o un centro
de calidad así que vamos a utilizar el
término centro quiral en este vídeo pero
también podrías oír esto está el
concepto de centro de calidad o estéreo
centro o centro estéreo génico o centro
asimétrico y todos son realmente se
refieren al mismo concepto verdad que es
un carbono que es tiene una forma de
letra erika que tiene una hibridación
sp3 verdad y tiene cuatro grupos
distintos unidos a él así que vamos a
buscar centros de quiralidad dos centros
quirales en estas moléculas ok y vamos a
empezar con este primer alcohol muy bien
vamos a tener este primer alcohol y
vamos a tratar de ubicar los centros
finales muy bien entonces aquí tengo
vamos a vamos a desarrollar esto digamos
en su diagrama de puntos y bueno en su
diagrama de líneas ok aquí tenemos estos
cuatro carbonos que corresponden a
nuestra cadena principal y veamos que
este primer carbono verdad
que tenemos digamos de este lado está
unido a tres hidrógenos verdad que
esencialmente si los vemos como grupos
pues son iguales entonces este grupo de
aquí perdón este carbono de aquí no
puede ser un centro cuidado vamos a ver
qué pasa con este segundo este segundo
pues está unido por un lado
el grupo hidroxilo verdad que es el h y
por otro lado está unido al hidrógeno
verdad entonces estos dos esencialmente
son grupos distintos y los vemos aquí
pues aquí se encuentra nuestro hidrógeno
verdad entonces estos dos son grupos
distintos si nos fijamos hacia la
derecha verdad hacia la derecha en
realidad está unido a un grupo estilo
mientras que hacia la izquierda se
encuentra unido a un grupo metilo
entonces realmente podemos ver que este
carbono es un centro que ir al de
nuestra molécula ahora bien en el
segundo en perdón en el tercer carbono
que corresponde a este de aquí tenemos
que esto está unido a dos hidrógenos y
que ya nada más por eso está unido a dos
grupos funcionales iguales entonces este
es este no sería un centro cuidado y
finalmente en este último este está
unido a tres hidrógenos verdad estos
tres hidrógenos son grupos funcionales
iguales y por lo tanto no es un centro
que irá así que aquí sólo tenemos un
centro tirar que es nuestro segundo
carbono
ahora vamos a ver qué pasa con este esta
molécula que tenemos aquí vamos a pintar
digamos su diagrama vamos a tener un
carbono aquí otro carbono y otro carbono
verdad el primer carbono como el último
están unidos a tres hidrógenos entonces
ninguno de estos dos carbonos puede ser
un centro que italia que está unido a
tres a tres grupos iguales verdad ahora
si nos fijamos en el del centro éste
tiene un doble enlace que conecta con un
oxígeno y inmediatamente podemos deducir
que este carbono de aquí tiene una
hibridación sp2 verdad entonces
inmediatamente podemos decir que no no
es un centro quiral ya que tiene que
tener una hibridación sp3 para poder
tener una geometría te trae drica y
además de todo pues podemos ver que no
hay cuatro grupos distintos verdad
tenemos dos metidos que de por sí ya se
repiten y tenemos un oxígeno entonces no
hay cuatro grupos distintos y por lo
tanto esta molécula tiene cero centros
que ir al es verdad
centros gira les vamos a ver otros
ejemplos aquí tenemos estos dos digamos
que están basados en anillos de
hidrocarburo más bien un hidrocarburo en
forma de anillo verdad vamos a buscar
centros quirales muy bien y lo lo
inmediato que podemos ver en este primer
ejemplo es que ninguno de estos que
estoy marcando con rojo puede ser un
centro király eso es muy fácil de ver
porque cada uno de estos tiene dos
enlaces que conectan a hidro a carbonos
perdón y tienen otros dos que conectan a
hidrógenos entonces esos dos hidrógenos
corresponderían a grupos funcionales
pero perdón grupo sustituye entes
iguales y entonces eso eso corresponde a
que no puede ser un centro que ir al
ahora si pensamos en este de aquí
explicamos como nuestro único candidato
realmente podemos ver que éste está
unido a un hidrógeno verdad ya un cloro
que ahí van dos grupos funcionales
distintos ahora tendríamos que
determinar si las otras dos
los otros dos digamos
las otras dos uniones determinan grupos
funciona el grupo sustituye entes
distintos y eso lo podemos ver
fijándonos en la trayectoria que se da
al recorrer en cada dirección de este
anillo verdad entonces si pensamos por
ejemplo en la dirección hacia la derecha
tenemos un ch 2 verdad 11 h 2c h 2c h 2c
h 2 tenemos una digamos una trayectoria
de sh2 verdad sí nos vamos hacia la
izquierda tenemos se h 12 h 12 h 2c h 2c
h 2 verdad entonces realmente tenemos la
la misma trayectoria ya sea si nos vamos
hacia hacia el digamos el sentido de las
manecillas del reloj o en dirección
contraria a las manecillas del reloj
entonces dado que son las mismas
trayectorias podemos pensar que son los
mismos grupos sustituye entes y por lo
tanto no es un centro que irá al verdad
otra forma por ejemplo de pensarlo es
digamos si tenemos aquí nuestro carbono
que ya está
a un hidrógeno y a un cloro y esto
digamos está unido a dos grupos verdad
este grupo de aquí digamos vamos a
marcarlo con azul este grupo de aquí es
un grupo de tilo y este otro de aquí
también verdad entonces realmente se
parecen a los mismos grupos unidos al
carbono verdad en este caso y no es un
centro que irá ahora vamos a ver que en
el otro caso si es si tenemos un centro
que ir a la verdad entonces nuevamente
aquí tenemos que este carbono de aquí
está unido a dos hidrógenos este carbono
de aquí está unido a otros dos
hidrógenos este de aquí también a dos
hidrógenos y entonces estos tres que
tenemos aquí no pueden ser candidatos
para hacer centros quirales porque están
unidos a dos grupos iguales verdad
entonces cuál sería una propuesta pues
por ejemplo podría ser una propuesta
este de aquí verdad que era como el caso
similar al a la molécula anterior verdad
entonces aquí podemos ver que está unido
a nuestro cloro pero también está unido
a uno
hidrógeno entonces estos dos en
principio son grupos distintos ahora
vamos a ver qué pasa si recorremos la
molécula en esta dirección o si la
recorremos en esta otra dirección y si
la recorremos en dirección de las
manecillas del reloj podemos ver que
estamos uniendo a un ch verdad aquí
tenemos un carbono que tiene un doble
enlace hacia abajo y un enlace simple
hacia arriba faltaría uno sencillo que
es un hidrógeno verdad aquí tenemos un
enlace extra un hidrógeno y lo mismo
pasaría con esta verdad tenemos otro
hidrógeno entonces la cadena digamos
esta trayectoria sería ch ch ch 2 si
recorremos en dirección contraria es c h
2c h 2c h2 entonces realmente son grupos
distintos porque no representan la misma
trayectoria digamos en ese orden verdad
entonces este de aquí este que estoy
marcando si es
un centro final de esta molécula ahora
bien ya no hay más por la sencilla razón
de que esté carbono de aquí y este
carbono de aquí al tener un enlace doble
tienen una híbridas una hibridación de
s&p 2 verdad entonces no hay más centros
finales sólo tenemos este de aquí verdad
vamos a ver un último ejemplo que por
supuesto va a ser un poquito más
complicado pero es muy muy interesante y
lo vamos a ir haciendo con cuidado
verdad entonces vamos a ir viendo por
ejemplo qué pasa en este anillo de
benceno aquí todos estos carbonos tienen
enlaces dobles en sus conexiones verdad
entonces eso significa que la
hibridación de cada uno de estos
carbonos es sp2 entonces estos de aquí
están excluidos como candidatos para
hacer centros quirales por otro lado qué
pasa con un con este carbono de aquí
bueno este carbono de aquí está unido a
dos carbonos y por lo tanto está
implícito que está unido a dos
hidrógenos lo cual lo excluye como
candidato a ser centro que ir a la
verdad por qué
dos grupos iguales que están conectados
a ese carbono lo mismo pasa con estos
dos de aquí porque estos dos de aquí
tienen unidos o está implícito que están
unidos a tres hidrógenos verdad estos
dos están unidos a tres hidrógenos
entonces ninguno de estos que hemos
marcado con rojo son centros quirales
vamos a ver qué pasa con este de aquí
este es un caso bastante interesante
verdad tenemos tres conexiones eso
quiere decir que por aquí hay un
hidrógeno que está implícito y hacia acá
arriba tenemos todo un grupo metilo
verdad este es un grupo metilo y tenemos
un hidrógeno hacia la derecha tenemos un
ácido carboxílicos que difiere de los
otros dos grupos que hemos encontrado y
hacia abajo pues queda mucho más claro
que este es un grupo completamente
distinto a los que tenemos verdad por
ejemplo aquí tenemos un anillo de
benceno que no tenemos en ninguno de los
otros tres grupos entonces este de aquí
es un centro final de esta molécula
ahora bien qué pasa cuando nos paramos
por ejemplo acá arriba
aquí arriba tenemos aquí un carbono que
tiene tres conexiones con hidrógenos
verdad tiene tres hidrógenos unidos son
grupos iguales entonces este no es un
centro quiral y si nos fijamos en este
último carbono éste tiene un enlace
doble lo cual quiere decir que tiene una
hibridación sp2 así que realmente este
es el único centro cuidad de esta
molécula que por cierto es el ibuprofeno
así que esta es realmente una habilidad
muy importante que hay que practicar
tenemos que fijarnos en los carbonos
pensar que es lo que está unido a ellos
y si tenemos cuatro grupos distintos
unidos ha dicho carbono verdad si es un
carbono tetraedro verdad con una
hibridación sp3 entonces podemos decir
que es un centro girar o un centro de
quiralidad o cualquier término que tu
profesor prefiera utilizar